je crois qu'il en est même pas conscient
il fait partie de le président macron de
ces catégories sociales qui ont fait
sécession d'avec la masse du peuple
français
ces gens qui vivent entre eux qu'ils ne
se rendent pas compte de ce qui peut y
avoir de de blessant à dire dans les
gares il ya ceux qui ont réussi leur vie
et ceux qui ne sont rien jamais même la
droite ne nous a parlé comme ça quand il
dit j'en ai marre qu'on dise la
pénibilité du travail comme si le
travail était pénible bon bien sûr le
mien de travail est moins pénible que
celui d'un égoutier mais en attendant
l'égoutier ce son travail heureusement
qu il le fait parce que sinon ni vous ni
moi ne serait ici en train de de parler
tranquillement donc ça a été ressenti
comme autant de gifles
si bien avec la france et labouré par
les conséquences de ce mépris social et
nous ne savons pas comment les gens vont
réagir à ça vous ne savez pas je ne le
sais pas ce que ce que l'on observe
depuis les élections de 2017 c'est que
les partisans du président de la
république ont tout fait pour assimiler
la france insoumise avec le
rassemblement national
comme si en fait il y avait une grande
bataille une unique bataille entre
progressistes d'un côté populiste de
l'autre et que la variable de gauche
avaient été réduites à néant
est-ce que vous avez la pression je suis
sûr que oui mais vous allez me dire en
quoi la gauche a encore est encore
capable de se distinguer aujourd'hui
dans ses propositions dans sa vision du
monde
bien sûr mais commençons par le début
c'est une ruse politique qui a permis
l'élection du président macron les gens
pas voté pour lui ils ont noté contre
madame le pen en tout cas un nombre
considérable a été convaincu que c'était
ça qu'il fallait faire bon comme c'est
une martingale électorale ça marche pas
c'est miracle qui a un besoin de faire
ça marche tout seul
c'est pourquoi j'avais été conduits à
dire que madame le pen est en quelque
sorte l'assurance vie du système parce
que une table une chaise
macron contre elle c'est l'autre qui
gagne bon mais après il essaye de
reproduire ça dans des conditions qui
sont désastreuses parce que ils ne se
rendent pas compte que il d'abord les
gens ne le croient pas ils ont cru un
temps mais dire que les insoumis et
le rassemblement national c'est la même
chose
tout le monde sait que c'est pas vrai
d'ailleurs les insoumis le savent
évidemment mais aussi les membres du
rassemblement national parce que nous
nous affrontons à peu près partout et
sur à peu près tout et puis les gens qui
sont des faut pas prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles c'est toujours l'erreur de
la macro ni prennent les gens pour des
crétins des demeurés qui sont incapables
de d'analysé
[Musique]